[Music]
it's been almost
two weeks since alexei navalny fell into
a coma on an early morning flight from
siberia
these his terrible cries of pain on
board before he lost consciousness
which russian medical staff attributed
to low blood sugar levels
now this stark announcement from the
german chancellor
alexey navalny alexanovani was the
victim of an attack with a chemical
nerve agent of the novichok group
this poison could be identified
unequivocally in tests
so it's clear that alexis navalny is the
victim of a crime
darmit is zika he was supposed to be
silenced and i
together with the entire german
government condemned us in the strongest
possible terms
angela merkel says she will discuss a
response with eu and nato partners
in a statement the foreign secretary
dominic raab called the use of novichok
unacceptable
he said the russian government has a
clear case to answer
it must tell the truth about what
happened to mr navalny
but will it alexei navalny is the man
president putin famously refuses to
mention by name
he is the kremlin's most outspoken
critic and a tireless anti-corruption
campaigner his family
and his foundation have always
maintained this is the direct work of
the kremlin
but the tone from the top true to form
remains dismissive
the kremlin saying they're prepared to
cooperate with german authorities
but that they want more information from
the german side uh
if uh russian authorities theoretically
theoretically would be so greatly
barbaric
that they decided to poison uh receive
was the reason to send him to the
germany
no reason so uh
not barbaric we are putin and he keep
not poisoning his political ambulance
president would suggest otherwise alexei
navalny has always lived on borrowed
time
asked the day before he was poisoned as
he has been numerous times on his
travels
how he'd managed to survive for so long
for now he is still in a coma on a
ventilator
in berlin's charity hospital for its
part
the kremlin has still to launch a
criminal investigation
diana magnay sky news moscow